this hour the body found dismembered in
coolers has been identified now as 65
year old richard miller we're also
learning more about the criminal history
of the man accused of killing him the 8
news now i-team broke this story of eric
holland's arrest last week trucks
holland was driving contained the
coolers with miller's body parts bianca
holman joining us now in studio holland
appeared before a judge on the murder
charge bianca
well in court on tuesday a discussion on
eric holland's long criminal history
that started in the 1970s the
prosecution listed charges for every
decade all the way into his most recent
arrest for murder
eric holland was escorted into the
courtroom in chains with four officers
and his public defender this court
appearance was his justice court
arraignment on murder the state
requested no bail because of his long
criminal history spanning four decades
which ranged from embezzlement to
assault the state also highlighted the
gruesomeness of the case which the eight
news eye team learned about from metro
lieutenant ray spencer we've recovered
evidence that shows that he purchased
tools that were used to dismember the
victim's body and then placed him into
several ice chests that we recovered
during the initial arrest the prosecutor
presented receipts found listing the
purchase of trash bags and ties they
also shared a picture of holland in a
home depot with a saw in his shopping
cart judge harmony leticia made a
decision regarding his custody so for
today's purposes mr holland is going to
remain held without mail
i would like to have the detective here
just to lay the appropriate foundation
and no word yet on why holland allegedly
killed richard miller what we know right
now is that miller was an acquaintance
of holland holland will be back in court
on tuesday where bail will be discussed
bianca holman live local now